I have a great book recommendation for
you today it is called waves of rancor
tuning into the radical right this is a
more academic read by Hillard and Keith
it's a book I recently read for a new
project I have coming up and the book
outlines in really really factual and
empirical ways the reality that number
one there is no corporate liberal media
number one but number two how the
airwaves in the US have been used for a
very long time dating all the way back
to father Coughlin and uh Winchell and
eventually with the advent of more
modern talk radio everything from the
armed militias and conspiracy theorists
to the religious right and white
supremacist neo-nazis etc they have been
using media for a very long time to
achieve political desires and this book
is just chock-full of data it's based on
interviews it's based also I talked a
little bit recently about how groups
like the anti-defamation league in
Southern Poverty Law Center categorize
different types of extremist groups and
I talked about how even within the
so-called white supremacist movement
there's depending on who you ask
anywhere from three to five groups
including neo-nazis white supremacists
Aryan prison gangs so on and so forth
the book is going to get you very much
up to speed not only on the types of
extremist groups that exist and
interestingly enough this book again I
have mentioned this before very often
academics in this field include the
Nation of Islam and at least the Al
Sharpton that existed in the 90s al
Sharpton is sort of moderated more
recently but al Sharpton in the nation
of islam have many of the exact same
characteristics as the neo-nazi Aryan
and white supremacist groups this is an
excellent excellent read it is a little
bit dense I will not pretend that it's
not because it is a more academic book
but this would be actually very
enlightening to people in our audience
who are track
movement like the alt right you would
have to hope that this is kind of
slowing down though with the emergence
of new media because it's not like shows
like ours are being controlled by other
outside interests and so if there are
other parties that play who try to
influence what people on hate radio are
saying yeah you'd like to think that's
kind of downplayed by now that is true
at the same time the book talks about
how new media is also used by many of
these forces so it does another chapter
there's sort of two sides to that coin
no doubt about it so again the book is
waves of rancor tuning in the radical
right it's by Hillard and Keith I highly
highly recommend this book and of course
you can find this and all of my
recommendations at david pakman.com
forward slash recommendations i am on
twitter at d pakman i am available for
any questions comments criticisms or
concerns we will take a break and be
back with your calls next